for the last three months we've been
working on these VFX makeover videos
we've fixed the Scorpion King we've
changed the muzzle flashes in John wick
and we even made a Marvel movie r-rated
and so I got to wondering about one of
the most brutal movies of all time home
alone which I know it's the children's
movie it's not violent but when you
think about it it really is it's a very
brutal movie so we decided to give it
the brutality it deserves so today we're
gonna make home alone r-rated we're here
to do the first look at the home defense
scene and the original home alone movie
we're gonna be going through picking
some of our favorite moments where Kevin
is defending the house from the bad guys
and seeing how he can reimagine this
entire scene we have enough time for
about four or five shots yeah
Peter said he could do a shot remotely
from school Peter's special we need to
give her the most insane
I think the first obvious one is right
here he's holding a gun hmm sound
effects he's just dead this is blossom
Thomas dude isn't so much time isn't
literally gonna be like this this should
be the Peter shot
I feel like this shot was made for Peter
dude that just has to get lodged
straight into test just straight in like
halfway through his head and it just
moves wherever his head goes so this
one's we have a video that J Kruger from
vsauce3 did exploring the possibility of
all these things and like the drn's that
they would do due to his skin tore off
the bottles book and then when he lands
right there
just seeing the nail we could probably
do like a CG foot rip it down the middle
and add guts on the inside
his entire body gets just engulfed in
flames all I think if your eyeballs
actually get hot enough because there
contains vessel the pressure would
increase until they pop his eyes should
definitely pop you guys give up oh yeah
thirsty for more we needed to take
people's expectations of Kevin
McCallister and flip them on its head
and make him the villain so what about
this what if Kevin McCallister
advertises on Airbnb Joe Pesci and the
robbers are actually just guys who are
coming to like stay there everybody Hey
well this looks like a great house I'm
really excited to be staying here but
you sure picked a good one off Airbnb
Harry we're turning Kevin McCallister
into a psychotic serial killer David he
makes his escape dude like you hear cop
sirens and you just escape something
that's the game plan we've got the iron
nail and the fire fire I'll get started
on them yet Neal
Logan sit on the iron I think this is
gonna be great well let's get it so my
task here for this video the main one
the one that I was really looking
forward to is causing this guy pain
in the actual movie his foot hovers over
the snail and then he freaks out and
falls backwards and holds his foot it's
like he obviously like presses it down a
little bit but he doesn't do more than
that so what I ended up doing was I
decided to make him totally step on it's
like first step is you got to create a
clean plate you got to remove the foot
from the shot at the very beginning of
the shot it's very convenient look at
all this empty space you take a
freeze-frame of that and track it back
into the footage so the second thing you
do completely rotoscope out his foot now
I could be like whoo foot Footloose okay
moving them now I can actually animate
it going down and over a female this is
what I love about doing visual effects
cuz it's all just problem-solving and I
have this big problem here for one he's
missing at the top of his leg but that's
easy enough you just duplicate this and
you slide it upwards duns the hard part
here is getting his foot to align with
the ground and to do that I did
something interesting
I used the liquify tool I basically just
like smudged everything up in the place
and then from there you had some contact
shadows it actually looks like his foot
is making contact with the step
obviously we got a color the nail to be
read at some blood elements this shot is
now done for the shower his foot
actually rips through the nail that's
not a shot that exists don't forget his
foot is still completely like I can move
it around and stuff and what if I just
like take it and slide it out the back
that's basically the animation right
there but that's not good enough I need
to animate his leg actually starting to
fall back a little bit and then tugging
a little bit on his foot I even bend the
nail a little bit so it's bending and
bending and then at the moment of give
it stops bending because there's no more
force on it so I have some blood
elements kind of going in different
directions here so kind of like it pops
and splashes in different ways
so Marv here he falls down and he's
holding his ankle from his little
boo-boo that he got from when he just
nicked a nail but no I need to make him
scream in agony because he split his
foot in half basically just completely
rotoscope out his foot so now I have
this massed about foot that I can
literally just move anywhere so I just
rotated it a little bit just like this
now I did actually kind of animate the
foot in place a little bit so that when
he falls down it kind of closes them
when he goes back up again it opens up a
little bit
currently there's nothing inside the
foot to see there's meat in there we
gotta see that tissue so I threw this in
what this is literally in this shot I
just googled steak and I found it a
really high-resolution image of a steak
it's very subtle and that's the point
here this is really disturbing but you
know what it's not nearly disturbing
enough I decided to add some blood but
yeah so I mean that's essentially those
three shots but you know what doing all
of this blood adding all this blood to
these shots has made me kind of think
maybe we should try something that's the
opposite of this what if we like took a
really violent movie and tried to make
it as g-rated as possible what if we
took like Deadpool and made it super
gene g-rated Deadpool or if you think of
a better movie that deserves a G rating
let us know and we'll talk about next
now they've done studies traumatic
experiences you are more likely to
remember than good experiences these
guys out here they're all working really
hard on this home alone raided our piece
they look a little too safe a little too
secure that's why I'm gonna throw at
them some good old-fashioned home alone
stunts courtesy of today's sponsor
expressvpn now these stunts are gonna
exemplify just how dangerous it can be
to have your information out on the open
Internet and I'm hoping with a little
bit of trauma they'll remember I'm just
a little bit better than they might
otherwise let's get started everything
is set up Sam's gonna be the victim
right here right now check this out hey
Sam what's up man I got something really
important to talk to you about could you
come in the back please like a podcast
back or like the prop room back did you
know that a VPN protects your
information online so companies and
guests please can't steal it from you
yeah it creates anonymity and security
No all right Clint's coming back right
now it looks like he's on his one wheel
here he comes here he comes
you know that expressvpn is available in
over 94 countries bales your
best-in-class encryption and the fastest
speeds I mean wow
freaking wrist
alright guys for my final trick out of
Kevin's playbook I've got the classic
toys on the ground with the paint can to
the face now this one I think they're
really gonna remember why would you
forget when expressvpn is just seven
bucks a month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee hey guys there's something
super cool back here that's right Wes
it's three months free when you sign up
for a year just go to expressvpn dots
cop slash corner crew really hurt
[Music]
that's expr ESS VPN calm such corridor
crew
is frozen we've done a couple of these
VFX makeovers and now with home alone
how do we take that even a step further
why is Kevin killing these people why is
Kevin murdering his men just watching
through home alone it occurred Kevin is
already a bullied youngest child like
there's this scene where if you want a
somebody's gonna have to barf it all up
look at this they're bullying him what
if that scene just went south what if
Kevin was harboring years more of
anxieties from his family what if Kevin
was a psychopath ranan Clint are busy
making the physical damage of Kevin's
traps realistic and I'm busy making his
psychological damage from his family
realistic so then it's like okay well
what tools do we have to work with
within home alone so apparently Kevin
has the biggest family in the world that
probably could drive someone mad in
itself having that many brothers and
sisters there's this guy he probably was
the reason Kevin snapped Kevin might
snap some Calicut axe and starts like
trying to tackle him
okay so there's something I can work
with like it look his little hand goes
up I think if you had a knife sound
effect there it can sound like he's
pulling a knife out there goes
everywhere it's perfect it's like
chaotic shots that can be
recontextualized I went back and took to
the closeup of his brother and lurching
move that after Kevin draws a knife
tackles him that's him getting stabbed
now so it's all about those moments like
finding these little moments like Kevin
saying I made my family disappear the
way he says I made my family disappear
is just so twisted so yeah this turned
into a far larger editing project than
originally anticipated but I think it
turned out pretty solid now we just need
to go record some custom ADR we're
redoing the voices for all the bad guys
so basically all the context we're gonna
get Jake and Sam screams we need
dialogue I think it's all gonna come
together really well so let's go do that
I'm playing Harry and Henry listen
there's Newark and then there's New York
okay the two different places don't get
it wrong we live in we're not from New
York were from Newark right okay just do
some tape give me some tapes hey Dan
this is Harry with the Airbnb
reservation the owner said to give them
a call when we arrived that was it that
was really good
is this a hard-working man from Newark
it's like I can't control this stuff
yeah it's all just impulse Wow how I
knew you could
no no you could Wow who knew you did who
knew you could get such a nice place on
air B&B just you just stop recording it
just stop recording recording it now no
who knows what I'm doing you get such a
nice place on Airbnb that's sucked on a
B&B
you want a two-stage err dry - wet dry -
wet
[Applause]
see you guys at the academy this is a
great moment for this week because
everyone here worked on this video
everyone here we're seeing it with all
the parts together for the first time I
think it came out super good I'm so
excited for you guys to see this I know
that Peter did a shot
you all know Peter he is a VFX magician
a prodigy I'm very excited to see that
shot let's watch it you are such a
disease you stir it alone just
disappeared
I've made my family disappear
haven't you completely help us you are
such a disease a little jerk doing her
new family
my family disappear here it is mom Wow
who knew you could get such a nice place
on Airbnb yeah she's okay the owner said
to give him a call when we arrived yes
this is Harry with the Airbnb
reservation and we're just pulling up
now is it still all right if we let
ourselves in
yes
[Music]
actually we made pretty good time let's
see here you're downstairs I'm up right
downstairs
screw Jace I'm going upstairs I'll sleep
on the couch if I have to
you should gonna turn your tail oh yeah
being baked looks just like the pictures
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is where we're staying
this is gonna be the best twin brothers
convention that ever show is looks like
Harry and Marv already got the party
started to say who the hell is that all
good party star in the back door on my
right knock hello I can fit through here
sure don't keep scared
[Music]
[Applause]
my favorite shot was shut up an
expansion like he simulated his hair
it's crazy you know means making those
news I think that's really really well
done I think most importantly bet the
re-edit it is really what makes it all
work it's the Edit that actually brings
the news story and makes it really funny
and entertaining other people have done
visual effects on home alone before but
no one's actually ready to make Kevin
McCallister look like a psychopath I've
made my family disappear the most subtle
of effects the second van there's the
first band that Harry and Marv pull up
in and then later on in the piece Henry
and Mark pull up in their other thing
they're like we want more Harry and Marv
kills but we like how do we justified
these guys are saying like hey why don't
we do it like a twin convention thing
that's going on so what started as just
like a regular crew video has now turned
into a full-fledged like corridor
Channel videos so you should definitely
go check that out on the corridor
channel a standalone you can share with
your friends if you guys haven't seen
the other makeover videos that we've
done please check them out there's a
playlist in the description of this
video and if you have any other movies
or shows that you'd like to see us
remake please let us know in the
comments we'll be checking it out did
you know that 60% of the people who
watch this video right now are not even
subscribed guys are trippin you got a
subscribe why would you subscribe you
know I'm actually offended that you
didn't subscribe so right now just gonna
hit the button press there you go you
know you should be doing you should be
hitting
so to subscribe and be notified of
future videos that's right
[Music]